yo you have a relationship with shotty
right
yes sir um
how's he doing are you still in contact
with him he's doing great
every day i talk to him he just says uh
another day at the office man
getting some getting some rest working
out it's another day at the office yeah
that's uh you know there's this this
whole situation that he's been a part of
just kind of got reignited online with
this whack 100 interview and a lot of
that stuff kind of what's your take on
on you know
it seems to be like i feel like there's
some sort of
part of the industry that's starting to
try to push 69 back in our face a little
bit i felt like [ __ ] had kind of got put
to bed after he put his [ __ ] out and it
kind of flopped but like kind of what's
your thoughts on what's going on right
now with all that [ __ ]
he's a rat
a rodent
i don't know like i don't i don't even
be i don't even be watching this [ __ ] he
do or whatever this is that's like you
know he sent people to jail he took
people away from their kids man like
here right here wrote and he just scum
of the earth bro there's no that's like
me sitting here and discussing a
pedophile like do you already know what
it is like
that he is a because i think that that's
what the one thing whack was saying no
he's a rat he's a rat yeah because whack
was like he's a civilian who told the
truth
once you do a street act that that takes
you out of that discussion
you consciously do a street act yeah no
yeah that's what you're not a civilian
no more that's what glasses you choose
to pick up a gun and walk outside right
now you know what's coming out of the
civilian no more that's an illegal crime
you're a criminal yeah
yeah no that's kind of uh you know
shout out to my guy
malone out here that's kind of what he's
just rodent